two sides of the same wall  where i come from societies are quite  divided with visible walls protecting  against supposed dangers walls marking  limits of properties marking borders  separating ethnic or religious groups  but there are also invisible walls the  ones in the minds of people i grew up in  peru mexico bolivia germany and the  former yugoslavia and if nothing else  they all had that one thing in common  i've always wondered what kind of  stories i can find on both sides of the  wall this is why i became a journalist  walls are borders based on fears and  cliches but as it turns out the stories  are often very similar on both sides  with fake news running rampant it's more  important than ever to go out and talk  to people to understand their point of  view to keep on being interested and  curious on both sides of the wall  because the truth is never just on one  side  my name is carolina chimoy and i work at  dw  [Music]